Hey, this is a very quick intro for SmartList. Super, super fast. Can I ask you a quick question, though, before we... I know we're doing a quick intro. No, no, no. You're a SmartList. I know it's quick. No, we're gonna get to it in one second.
嘿，这是 SmartList 的一个非常简短的开场白。超级超级快。不过在我继续之前，我可以问你一个简单的问题吗……我知道我们在做一个简短的开场。不，不，不。你就是一个 SmartList。我知道这很快。不，我们马上就会说到正题。
Okay, go, go, go, go. Can I ask you a quick question? What is it? What's the rush, man? Oh, God. It's SmartList. Smart. Smart.
好吧，说，说，说，说。我能问你个简单的问题吗？什么问题？着什么急啊，老兄？哦，天哪。这是 SmartList。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Living. Esta. Jason, good morning. Good morning. Good morning, Jason.
聪明。聪明。聪明。生活。埃斯塔。杰森，早安。早安。早安，杰森。
How's your morning been? Well, it's been stressful. I just went through 45 minutes of tech, hell, because I bought a new laptop and... Why did you buy a new laptop? Why did you get the new one? Why did you need it? Okay. Well, here's the thing.
你早上过得怎么样？嗯，挺有压力的。我刚刚经历了 45 分钟的技术地狱，因为我买了一台新笔记本电脑，然后……你为什么买新笔记本电脑？你为什么要买个新的？你为什么需要它？好吧。事情是这样的。
You've got a couple of kids. Now, the laptops that they're using, are they not your old laptops or do you buy them Freshies. Now, both my kids don't have a laptop, only my 13 year old. Okay, what about him? Do you buy him a new one or do you give him your old one? We got him a new one, his own one,
你有一对儿女。现在，他们用的笔记本电脑，难道不是你的旧笔记本电脑，还是你给他们买全新的。现在，我的两个孩子都没有笔记本电脑，只有我 13 岁的孩子有。好吧，他呢？你给他买了个新的，还是把你的旧的给他了？我们几年前在开学时给他买了个新的，他自己的。
a couple of years ago for school. Okay. Well, okay, so I give a hand me down a laptops to my girls and... Has somebody got construction going on? Is it one of us? It's not mine. It's me, yeah, do you like that?
好吧。好吧，所以我把淘汰的笔记本电脑给我的女儿们，然后……有人在施工吗？是我们当中的一个人吗？不是我的。是我，对，你喜欢这样吗？
Good for you. Is that the work on your house? Yeah, I can open up the windows right of the right. Well, you just ask them if they can do it louder. Sure, yeah, that's what I'm saying. Are you... This is the fucking gang who couldn't shoot
那可真棒。那是你房子在施工吗？对，我可以把窗户直接打开。好吧，你干脆问问他们能不能弄得更大声点。当然，可以，我就是这个意思。你们是……今天早上这群笨手笨脚的家伙都在这儿。
straight over here this morning. It's gonna be the best episode ever. You don't wanna take them to fucking have them powered down while we're doing the report. What am I gonna do? They're in the trenches of my driveway because there's leakage and they have to reroute the gas line and...
这将是有史以来最好的一集。在我们在做播客的时候，你难道不想让他们停工一会儿吗？我能怎么办？他们在我的车道上挖沟，因为有泄漏，他们必须重新铺设燃气管道，然后……
I had some leakage this morning and it didn't affect my start time, just my laptop replacement did. Yeah, but otherwise everything else going good? What about you? Will, is everything perfect in your world? It seems like it. No, well, I mean, sort of, I've been working,
我今天早上也有点泄漏，这没影响我的开始时间，只有更换笔记本电脑影响了。对，但除此之外一切都挺好？你呢？威尔，你的世界一切完美吗？看起来是的。不，我是说，算吧，我一直在工作，
I've been finishing off, I just signed up. You know, I'm doing my new show, my Murderville show over there on the Netflix. Oh, let's plug that real quick. What's it called? Murderville, and it's kind of a... Where can the viewers find that? They can watch it on Netflix.
我一直在收尾，我刚签约。你知道的，我在网飞（Netflix）制作我的新节目《谋杀村》（Murderville）。哦，让我们快点宣传一下那个。叫什么名字？《谋杀村》，它有点像……观众在哪里可以看到？他们可以在网飞上观看。
And it's... At what time? I don't mean at what time. It's not a schedule, at whatever time they want. That's the whole point of screaming. What time does it come on? Is it like, what's a slot? 8 a.m.?
而且它是……几点播？我不是指几点。这不是按时间表的，他们想什么时候看就什么时候看。这就是流媒体的意义。几点上映？是不是像，有什么黄金档？早上 8 点？
No, it's not 830 Mountain. Right after Newhart? You know what I mean? What's the lead in? I mean, the local news. When does it premiere? We go local news, and then... But it's kind of like you saw it.
不，不是山地时间 8 点半。就在《纽哈特》（Newhart）之后？你知道我的意思吗？接档节目是什么？我是说，地方新闻。什么时候首播？我们播地方新闻，然后……但它有点像你看过的。
It's kind of a hybrid improv show. Oh, I want to see it. It comes on early Feb, first week of Feb, around the third or something. Short for February. Short for February. I don't have a lot of time. And you saw it.
它有点像是一个混合的即兴表演节目。哦，我想看。它在二月初上映，二月的第一周，三号左右。二月（February）的缩写。二月（February）的缩写。我没有太多时间。而且你看过。
Sean, you haven't seen the first episode, is Conan and me, and I have the guest... You can catch it on reruns though, right? You can catch it on reruns, and guests come on, and then they try to solve a murder with me, and they have no idea. I don't give them a script. I love it.
肖恩，你还没看过第一集，那是柯南和我，我有嘉宾……不过你可以在重播时看，对吧？你可以在重播时看，嘉宾会来，然后他们试图和我一起破获一起谋杀案，而他们完全不知道。我不会给他们剧本。我太喜欢了。
And this is a game show. So if they solve the murder, they win money? No, they don't win a car. They don't win money. They just win respect. So it's not a game show. It is an unscripted slash scripted experience. Yeah, experience.
这是一个游戏节目吗？如果他们破了案，他们能赢得奖金吗？不，他们赢不了一辆车。他们赢不了钱。他们只能赢得尊重。所以这不是一个游戏节目。它是一个非剧本加剧本的体验。对，体验。
And there's a lot of laughter, and we goof around. We have great guests, and they kind of improvise. We don't give them anything, and then I improvise with them, and we go and we interview suspects, and it's fun.
里面有很多笑声，我们一直在胡闹。我们有很棒的嘉宾，他们会进行即兴表演。我们不给他们任何东西，然后我和他们一起即兴发挥，我们去采访嫌疑人，这很有趣。
It's just good, clean, fun. That was a pretty long plug. Yeah, Murderville, streaming now on Netflix. Once you're like L.A. Law on NBC. 8.30. Well... Yeah, anyway. I need to get into loose, hijinksy chat mode.
这只是健康、纯粹的乐趣。刚才那段广告打得挺长。对，《谋杀村》，现在正在网飞上热播。就像国家广播公司（NBC）的《洛城法律》（L.A. Law）。8点半。好吧……对，不管怎样。我得进入那种轻松、恶作剧的聊天模式了。
Yeah, I know. I'm all stressed out in my tech mode. Well, guess what? This is gonna make you very happy then, because our guest likes to keep it loose and chatty. He is somebody that you... Jason, I think that you know, Sean, I'm not sure that you do.
对，我知道。我满脑子都是技术压力的烦恼。好吧，你猜怎么着？这会让你非常高兴，因为我们的嘉宾喜欢保持轻松和爱聊天的状态。他是一个你……杰森，我想你认识他，肖恩，我不确定你认不认识。
This is a guy who has done... Who's been really sort of like a trailblazer. He's kind of created his own universe, and that's very specific, and really funny, and really different, and he came on the scene, the scene. What scene? He sort of...
这家伙做过……他真的有点像个开拓者。他创造了自己的宇宙，非常独特，真的很好笑，真的很与众不同，他出现在这个圈子里，圈子。什么圈子？他有点……
Well, the murder scene. The murder scene. You know, he came on... Andrew Dice Clay. It's not Dice, but maybe he could do a Dice impression when he gets here. This is somebody who's super, super funny. He has created a whole sort of vibe.
嗯，谋杀现场。谋杀现场。你知道，他出现在……安德鲁·戴斯·克莱（Andrew Dice Clay）。不是戴斯，但也许他到了这里可以模仿一下戴斯。这是一个超级超级搞笑的人。他创造了一种全新的氛围。
He's a guy who is not afraid to get his hands dirty. In fact, he just gets his whole body in there. He was born with the name Philip John Clap. His friends call him PJ. You know, he's from Knoxville, Tennessee, so you know him as Johnny Knoxville. Johnny Knoxville! Hello, Louise.
他是一个不怕把手弄脏的家伙。事实上，他整个人都扑进去了。他出生时的名字叫菲利普·约翰·克拉普（Philip John Clap）。他的朋友们叫他 PJ。你知道，他来自田纳西州诺克斯维尔，所以你认识他叫约翰尼·诺克斯维尔（Johnny Knoxville）。约翰尼·诺克斯维尔！你好，路易斯。
Hello, PJ. Look at this guy. How you doing? Oh man. What's up? I'm so sorry to keep you waiting. All the tech garbage. I love being a witness to the soundcheck,
你好，PJ。瞧瞧这家伙。你好吗？哦，天哪。怎么了？很抱歉让你们久等了。一堆技术垃圾。我喜欢作为声音检查的见证者，
because I like seeing how the sausage is made. Yeah. There was dirty sausage this morning. Real dirty sausage. Yes. Did you witness how close to the edge Bateman was? Like how much he was so close to snapping? Like he's never seen a computer in his life.
因为我喜欢看香肠是怎么做出来的。对。今天早上有脏香肠。真正的脏香肠。是的。你亲眼目睹了贝特曼离崩溃边缘有多近吗？就像他离发飙有多近？就好像他这辈子没见过电脑一样。
I had that look on my face last night when we tried to do ads, right? And it totally blew up in my face. He did and he left. I tried to record yesterday. I mean, this man's in charge of people. He runs sets and he's never seen a computer in his life. He doesn't know what the computers do.
昨晚我们试着做广告的时候，我脸就是那个表情，对吧？结果彻底搞砸了。他确实这么做了，然后他走了。我昨天尝试录音。我的意思是，这家伙管着一帮人。他负责剧组，但他这辈子从没见过电脑。他根本不知道电脑是干什么用的。
And he was excited to have the new Monterey operating system, even though he doesn't know why it makes his life better. He's just excited because he liked it. You like the name, be honest. You like the name Monterey. Monterey was better than Catalina. And you actually thought that the laptop, and so you can only have it on your lap,
而且他很高兴能用上新的蒙特雷（Monterey）操作系统，尽管他根本不知道为什么这会让他的生活变得更好。他只是因为喜欢而高兴。说实话，你喜欢这个名字。你喜欢蒙特雷这个名字。蒙特雷比卡特琳娜（Catalina）好。而且你居然以为这台笔记本电脑，所以你只能把它放在膝盖上，
never on a table or anything else, right? Maybe that was, that's what I asked the guys. I said, now I've got my computer on a table. Could that be it? Yeah. They said, yeah, put it on your lap, you dumbass. PJ, where do we find you today? I'm in the city of Los Angeles.
绝对不能放在桌子或其他任何地方，对吧？也许是这样，这就是我问那些人的。我说，现在我的电脑放在桌子上。会是这样吗？对。他们说，对，把它放在你的膝盖上，你这个笨蛋。PJ，今天我们在哪里能找到你？我在洛杉矶市。
I just got finished recording my radio show with my cousin I do on Outlaw Country every week called the Big Ass Happy Family Jubilee. It ain't too good, but it's long. And that was Will's handle in high school, I think, right? Just like, and then they started calling him Pencil and then he, yeah. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, yeah.
我刚录完我和我表弟每周在“不法乡村”（Outlaw Country）上做的广播节目，名叫《大屁股快乐家庭盛典》（The Big Ass Happy Family Jubilee）。它虽然不太好，但时间很长。我想那是威尔在高中时的外号，对吧？就像，然后他们开始叫他铅笔，然后他，等等，等等，等等，等等，对。
I mean, okay, let's acknowledge. Now let's move on. So PJ, tell us, how long have you been doing this radio show? What are you talking about, man? I've been doing it. We've done over 500 shows. Wow.
我是说，好吧，让我们承认吧。现在我们继续。所以 PJ，告诉我们，你做这个你在说些什么，老兄？我一直在做。我们已经做了 500 多个节目了。哇。
Yeah, my cousin, Roger Allen Wade, and I do it once a week. It comes on Saturday nights at 8 p.m. Eastern, five specific and it's the highlight of my week. I get to hang out with him for an hour and we can play any music we want. Mostly good old 70s, Outlaw Country 60s, but we can play punk, we can play whatever.
对，我和我的表弟罗杰·艾伦·韦德（Roger Allen Wade）每周做一次。它在周六晚上东部时间 8 点，太平洋时间 5 点播出，这是我一周中的高光时刻。我可以和他一起闲逛一个小时，我们可以播放任何我们想要的音乐。主要是优秀的 70 年代老歌，60 年代不法乡村音乐，但我们也可以放朋克，放任何东西。
And I mean, we played Liza Minnelli. I'm in. Will and I played Liza Minnelli a little bit on the rest of development. I sure did. Yeah, that's right. I think we both kissed her. Yeah, we both kissed Liza Minnelli.
我的意思是，我们放过丽莎·明奈利（Liza Minnelli）。算我一个。威尔和我在《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）里稍微放了一点丽莎·明奈利的歌。我当然放了。对，没错。我想我们俩都吻过她。对，我们俩都吻过丽莎·明奈利。
It's something that we never thought we'd do. At the same time. Wow. I've never had the pleasure of meeting you. I don't think, or maybe briefly once a long, long time, do I call you PJ, do I call you Johnny? You can call me that, you can call me Puddin. Were you with LW1 back in the day?
这是我们从未想过会做的事。在同一时间。哇。我从来没有荣幸见过你。我想没有，或者可能很久很久以前有过短暂的一面之缘，我该叫你 PJ，还是叫你可以叫我那个，你叫我布丁（Puddin）。你以前在 LW1 工作过吗？
I don't know what that is. A commercial agency, LW1. Oh, me? No, I wasn't. You all look familiar to PJ, Sean. Cause you used to get every commercial back in the day. Sure, Sean used to get every commercial, like Tostito's Scoopers, I probably did that, right?
我不知道那是什么。一家商业广告公司，LW1。哦，我？不，我没有。你们俩对 PJ 来说都很面熟，肖恩。因为你以前拍过所有商业广告。没错，肖恩以前拍过所有商业广告，比如托斯蒂托斯勺形玉米片（Tostito's Scoopers），我可能拍过那个，对吧？
Cause they're so easy on game day to just scoop, right? That was your whole... No, maybe I saw you then. No, but do your friends, like your friends call you PJ? Yeah, yeah, PJ or Knoxville, you know, either. Okay, yeah. Every time you say PJ, I look at, Jason's sucking at somebody off camera saying,
因为比赛日用它来舀东西太方便了，对吧？那是你的全部……不，也许我那时见过你。不，但是你的朋友们，比如你的朋友叫你 PJ 吗？对，对，PJ 或者是诺克斯维尔，你知道的，都行。好吧，对。每次你叫 PJ，我看着，杰森在镜头外对某人吮吸着说，
what time are we wheels up? So listen, so PJ, let me ask you this. You mentioned the commercial work. So when you first came to Los Angeles many, many moons ago, did you move to LA to be an actor specifically? Cause I know you did a lot of commercials, right? Yeah, I moved to LA to become an actor, you know, the best thing to come out of Tennessee is I-40 West.
我们几点起飞？所以听着，PJ，让我问你这个。你提到了商业广告的工作。所以当你很多很多年前初到洛杉矶时，你搬到洛杉矶是为了专门当演员吗？因为我知道你拍了很多商业广告，对吧？对，我搬到洛杉矶是为了成为一名演员，你知道的，从田纳西州走出来的最好东西就是 40 号州际公路西向。
So I got out of town two weeks after high school and went to the Academy of American Academy of Dramatic Arts in Pasadena for their summer program. Wow, that's so cool. Wow. And I went like two weeks, it was a six week program. I went two weeks, didn't go back, you know? I was just interested in partying
所以我高中毕业两周后就离开了小镇，去了帕萨迪纳的美国戏剧艺术学院（American Academy of Dramatic Arts）参加他们的夏季项目。哇，太酷了。哇。我去了两周，这是一个为期六周的项目。我去了两周，就没再去，你知道吗？我只对聚会感兴趣，
and that's all I did for the first six years. Is that true? Yeah, I would take some acting classes and kind of pursue acting, but I was more interested in partying and that didn't stop until my then girlfriend got pregnant with my daughter and I'm like, oh, I need to do something and quick.
那是头六年我唯一做的事。真的吗？对，我会去上一些表演课，并尝试演戏，但我对聚会更感兴趣，这种情况一直持续到我当时的疯狂女友怀上了我的女儿，然后我想，天哪，我得做点什么，而且要快。
So I lived next door to Antoine Fouquois and he put me in touch with a casting director who got me an agent and my friend John Linsen put me in touch with the editor of Bikini Magazine and I started writing articles for them. That's what I really became focused when I knew I had a mouth to feed. Sure, I liked the idea that you go like,
所以我住在安东尼·福奎阿（Antoine Fuqua）隔壁，他把我介绍给了一个选角导演，后者给我找了个经纪人，我的朋友约翰·林森（John Linsen）把我介绍给了《比基尼》杂志（Bikini Magazine）的编辑，我开始为他们写文章。当我意识到有一张嘴要养活时，这才是我真正开始专注的事情。当然，我喜欢那种你说：
my then girlfriend got pregnant and I looked at the window and I thought, I got to jump out this window and film it. That was my best guess, man. Yeah? Like my father told Rolling Stone, they're like, why do you think he does what he does? He goes, well, he's like that Dominican baseball player.
我当时的疯狂女友怀孕了，我看着窗户心想，我得跳出这扇窗户并把它拍下来。这是我的最佳猜测，老兄。是吗？就像我父亲对《滚石》杂志（Rolling Stone）说的那样，他们问：你为什么觉得他会做他做的事？他说，嗯，他就像那个多米尼加棒球运动员。
He's not going to get off the island by bunting. So I had to really go for it. Yeah, I mean, tell me a little bit about, so obviously people, you really came into people's consciousness. Well, I'm sorry. Hold that thought for one second, Johnny. Am I too loud?
他不会通过バント（触击）离开这个岛的。所以我必须全力以赴。对，我是说，跟我聊聊，所以很明显人们，你真的进入了人们的视野。哦，对不起。约翰尼，请保持这个想法一秒钟。我声音太大了吗？
Yeah, it's a little hot. Let's just push the mic back by about, yeah. Now give us a sound check. There, check, check. One, two. Rob, you like that? Perfect, thank you. Great, thanks guys.
对，有点高。我们把麦克风往后推大约，对。现在给我们试个音。好，检查，检查。一，二。罗布，你喜欢这样吗？完美，谢谢。太好了，谢谢大家。
Yeah, I don't know what kind of levels you like on your radio gig, man, but you know. Yeah, are you on W Shout FM? Like what's going on? Dude, so, I mean, but you, you, you know, you know, everybody knows you from the nose and loves the Jackass show and the movies. You guys have made what, three movies so far?
对，老兄，我不知道你在电台演出时喜欢什么级别的音量，但你知道的。对，你在 W Shout FM 吗？这到底是怎么回事？老兄，我的意思是，但是你，你，你知道，每个人都从节目中认识你并热爱《蠢蛋搞怪秀》（Jackass）节目和电影。你们到目前为止拍了几部电影？
Well, Jackass Forever will be our fourth. It comes out February 4th, 2020. Right, I can't wait. Oh, right. That comes out the day after Murderville. Murderville, I hear so much about Murderville. Is that on Netflix? It's on Netflix, it's streaming on there.
嗯，《蠢蛋搞怪秀永久版》（Jackass Forever）将是我们的第四部。它于 2020 年 2 月 4 日上映。对，我等不及了。哦，对。那在《谋杀村》上映的第二天上映。《谋杀村》，我听到太多关于《谋杀村》的事了。那是在网飞上吗？它在网飞上，上面正在热播。
What time does that come on? The day before Jackass Forever at 8 p.m. Oh, okay, what's it's lead in? I'm doing all Jason's material. That's it, you've tapped it out. So now PJ, you're pregnant, you're growing a baby and you think I got to start grabbing some money and get the coffers all nice and full.
那是几点播出的？在《蠢蛋搞怪秀永久版》上映的前一天晚上 8 点。哦，好吧，它的接档节目是什么？我全盘照搬了杰森的梗。就是这样，你已经榨干了。所以现在 PJ，你怀孕了，你孕育了一个宝宝，你觉得我得开始抓紧赚钱，把小金库填得满满的。
So you start writing for Bikini Magazine, you've got an agent, you're doing auditions and you think, well, let me get a third form of possible income in filming stunts. Was this all sort of simultaneous? It, the stunts grew out of my writing, right? I did a lot of participatory journalism stuff, poor imitations of Hunter S. Thompson.
所以你开始为《比基尼》杂志写作，你有了经纪人，你在试镜，你心想，好吧，让我通过拍摄特技来获得第三种可能的收入。这些都是同时发生的吗？不，特技是从我的写作中发展出来的，对吧？我做了很多参与式新闻报道的东西，对亨特·S·汤普森（Hunter S. Thompson）拙劣的模仿。
And I had an idea where I wanted to test self-defense equipment on myself, pepper spray myself, stun gun, taser gun and shoot myself in the chest with a 38 while wearing a bulletproof vest. And... But wait, just pause just for a second there. Why?
我有一个想法，我想在自己身上测试防身装备，用胡椒喷雾喷自己，用电击枪、泰瑟枪，穿着防弹衣用 .38 口径手枪射击自己的胸口。然后……但是等等，就在那里停一下。为什么？
For an article, right? For an article. Okay. Let's just experience and then write about it. Yeah. Yeah, I saw someone get pepper spray, and a reporter get pepper spray on the news and it was the funniest thing I'd seen.
为了写一篇文章，对吧？为了写一篇文章。好吧。只是去体验一下，然后写下来。对。对，我看到有人被胡椒喷雾喷了，一个记者在新闻里被胡椒喷雾喷了，那是我见过最好笑的事情。
I'm like, what if I do a whole host of things to myself? Yeah. And a lot of magazines wanted me to do it. Sure, sure. But they wanted to treat it like a negative pickup and didn't want anything to do with it until I'm done. But I had zero cash at the time. I didn't have enough money to buy the pepper spray,
我想，如果我在自己身上做一整套事情会怎么样？对。很多杂志都想让我这么做。当然，当然。但他们想把它当作一个买断式收购（negative pickup）来对待，在我完成之前根本不想插手。但我当时一文不名。我没有足够的钱买胡椒喷雾，
the stun gun, the taser. I had to buy a bulletproof vest. Whoa. So I remember I used my mom's Christmas money that year, which was $300 and bought the cheapest bulletproof vest they made. And I... No corner you want to cut.
电击枪，泰瑟枪。我得买一件防弹衣。哇。所以我记得我用了我妈妈那年的圣诞钱，也就是 300 美元，买了我能买到的最便宜的防弹衣。我……没有你想省的角落。
Yeah, I called and I said, hey, are these really, is this vest really top form? They're, yeah, this is best, great, great bulletproof vest. And I said, good, because this is what I'm going to do. And they said, can we call you back? And I said, sure. And they called me back. We can't recommend you doing that one.
对，我打电话说，嘿，这些真的是，这件背心真的是顶级质量吗？他们说，对，这是最好、最好的防弹衣。我说，太好了，因为这就是我要做的。他们说，我们能给你回电话吗？我说，当然。然后他们给我回了电话。我们不建议你那样做。
I'm like, it's too late. I've already said I was going to. But anyway, I took it around. No one wanted to support me in it, except for one guy. And that was Jeff Tremaine, who was the editor of Big Brother Magazine, the skateboarding magazine owned by Larry Flint. And Jeff went on to create and direct Jackass
我说，太迟了。我已经说过我要做了。不管怎样，我拿着它到处跑。没有人支持我，除了一个人。那就是杰夫·特雷恩（Jeff Tremaine），他是拉里·弗林特（Larry Flynt）旗下的滑板杂志《老大哥杂志》（Big Brother Magazine）的编辑。后来杰夫和我与斯派克一起创作并导演了《蠢蛋搞怪秀》。
with me and Spike. So I wrote it for Big Brother Magazine. And the day before, a couple of days before I was going to write the article or do the shoot, Jeff said we should film it and put it in our skateboard video. Because they were filming skate videos at the time. And I said, all right.
所以我为《老大哥杂志》写了这篇文章。在前一天，在我写文章或进行拍摄的前几天，杰夫说我们应该把它拍下来，放进我们的滑板视频里。因为他们当时在拍摄滑板视频。我说，好吧。
And the day of I went to pick up the cameraman, Dimitri Eliaskovic, who became our director of photography on Jackass. We have a lot of high sounding titles for guys who don't know what they're doing. But anyway, Dimitri's on the side of the road. I'm like, okay, get in, let's go shoot. He goes, okay, here's play, here's pause, here's stop.
拍摄当天我去接摄像师迪米特里·埃利亚斯科维奇（Dimitri Eliaskovic），他后来成了我们《蠢蛋搞怪秀》的摄影指导。我们给那些不知道自己在做什么的家伙起了很多听起来很高大上的头衔。不管怎样，迪米特里站在路边。我说，好吧，上车，我们去拍摄。他说，好吧，这是播放，这是暂停，这是停止。
Just bring it back when you're done. I said, you're not coming. He goes, no, I can't come. Because even Big Brother didn't want anything to do with it because I was shooting myself. Yeah. So you had to pull the trigger yourself. You didn't have some, so it was point blank range,
拍完后带回来就行。我说，你不来吗？他说，不，我不能去。因为连《老大哥》都不想跟这事沾边，因为我要开枪射自己。对。所以你必须自己扣动扳机。你没有，所以那是零距离，
literally. My friend, beautiful Jason, was supposed to shoot me once we just drove out to 14 and pulled off on the fire road because we didn't know where to go. And he got out there, he goes, I'm not shooting you. You should have done it in front of a hospital, dumb dumb. Yeah. You don't drive as far as you can away
字面意思上的。我美丽的朋友杰森本来应该开枪射我的，我们只是把车开到 14 号公路，然后拐到消防通道上，因为我们不知道该去哪里。他下车后说，我不射你。你应该在医院前面做这事，笨蛋。对。你不会开车开到离任何文明地方尽可能远的地方。我们当时太远了，但我下车后没有人愿意开枪射我。而且摄影师以前看过他的一个朋友因为拍特技而死，从酒店跳下去。所以他非常害怕。所以我最后不得不自己开枪射自己，每个人都在尖叫着让我别这么做。
from any sort of civilization. We were so far, but I got out there and no one would shoot me. And also like the photographer had seen one of his friends die doing a stunt once, jumping off a hotel. So he was really freaked out. And so I had to end up shooting myself and everyone screaming not to do it.
我的摄像师拿着摄像机到处乱晃。就像他差点错过我开枪射自己一样。哦，天哪。哇。所以那不是空包弹，是真子弹？不，那是真的，对。对，没有作假。所以用 .38 口径的子弹在零距离射击
And my cameraman is like going all over with the camera. Like he almost misses me shooting myself. Oh my God. Wow. And so it wasn't a blank, it was a real bullet? No, it was a real, yeah. Yeah, there's no faking it. So 38 caliber bullet at point blank range
到一个廉价的胸部护具、防弹衣上。很明显一切都顺利吗？它把你击倒了吗？它弄疼你了吗？感觉就像有人用铲子往你胸口狠狠拍了一下。它把我震退了。我把枪掉了，但我没有倒下去。
into a bargain chest protector, bullet proof vest. And obviously everything worked out okay. Did it knock you down? Did it hurt you? What it felt like is someone took a shovel and hit you in the chest with it. It knocked me back. I dropped the gun, but I didn't fall down.
哇。防弹衣分散了冲击力。哇，哇。你太喜欢这种感觉了，以至于你想，嘿，那是一次很酷的体验。看看我还能做什么。这很有趣，但更重要的是，这是我知道自己能做的事。
Wow. The vest dispersed the impact. Wow, wow. And you liked it so much that you were like, hey, that was a cool experience. Let's see what else I could do. It was fun, but it was more of a matter of like, this is what I know I can do.
我觉得我能做到这一点。但你从小就是这么长大的吗？你小时候经常从高处往下跳吗？我小时候没那么夸张。我是有点精力旺盛，但还没到那个地步。对，这家伙去了帕萨迪纳的戏剧艺术学院。他可不是出来从楼上往下跳的。
I feel like I can do this. But did you grow up doing that? Were you jumping off shit when you were a kid? I wasn't so much like that as a kid. I mean, I was a little rambunctious, but not to that point. Yeah, no, this guy went to the Academy of Dramatic Arts in Pasadena. He wasn't coming out to like jump off buildings.
他本打算演莎士比亚。不，我知道，但这他妈的是一个相当晚才发现的才能，你到二十多岁才开始拿枪射击自己。你懂我的意思吗？他得养家糊口。嗯，他当时快要养活掘墓人的嘴了。你知道我的意思吗？
He was like gonna do Shakespeare. No, I know, but it's a fucking, it's a pretty late talent to learn that you got, like you're in your 20s and you start shooting yourself. You know what I mean? He had to feed mouths. Well, he was about to feed the undertaker's mouth. You know what I mean?
我来自田纳西州的一个小镇，生活节奏，你知道的。相当快。相当快。这就像在煤矿小镇长大一样。你知道的。你当时想赶紧离开那个鬼地方吗？你年轻的时候是这样吗？
I come from a very small town in Tennessee and life moves, you know. Pretty fast. Pretty fast. And it's like growing up in a coal mining town. It's, you know. Did you want to get the hell out of there? Were you like when you were young?
对，绝对是的。你意识到我必须离开这个鬼地方时多大？大概 16 岁。对。15，16 岁。因为那里的节奏比你天生的节奏要慢。
Yeah, for sure. How old were you when you realized like, I gotta get the fuck out of this place? Around 16. Yeah. 15, 16. Because it was slower than you naturally were sort of ticking.
我只知道如果我继续呆在那里，就会惹上麻烦，因为我的大部分朋友要么成了警察，要么进了监狱。对，相反你去了洛杉矶，选择了一条更安全的、朝自己胸口开枪的路线。没错。我是说，你知道的。现在，让我们听一段赞助商广告。
I just knew if I stuck around, it was gonna be trouble because most of my friends either became cops or went to jail. Yeah, instead you went out to Los Angeles for a safer route of shooting yourself in the chest. Right. I mean, it's, you know. And now, a word from our sponsor.
现在，回到节目中。所以一旦发生这种情况，你成功地用枪射击了自己的胸口。这制作成了一个很棒的视频。难道你，我的大脑会立刻想到，好吧，如果我要以此为生的话，根据定义，所有事情都需要不断升级。就像下一件事需要更大、更好、
And now, back to the show. So once this happens, you successfully shoot yourself in the chest. It makes for a great video. Do you, don't you, my brain would immediately go to, okay, if I'm gonna make a living at this by sort of definition, everything needs to be an escalation. Like the next thing needs to be bigger, better,
比朝自己胸口开枪更危险。你难道没有被那种压力压垮吗？不，直到我们考虑制作《蠢蛋搞怪秀》第二部时，我才被那种压力压垮。当我做第一篇关于自卫的文章时，我只想继续做那些风格相同、有趣且引人入胜的事情。
more dangerous than shooting myself in the chest. Were you not overwhelmed with the pressure of that? No, I didn't become overwhelmed with the pressure of that until we thought about making Jackass number two. At the time when I did my first article with the self-defense, I just wanted to continue doing things that were in the same vein and interesting and funny.
那时候我没有感到压力。我觉得自己有了新发现。这是一切的开始。但这难道不是一个系列吗？在它成为电影之前，它不是一个系列吗？难道不是吗？对，我们在电视上播了大约 9 到 10 分钟。9 到 10 个月，然后我辞职了。
I didn't feel pressure at that time. I felt like I was onto something new. It was the beginning of something. But wasn't it a series? Wasn't it a series before it was a movie, right? Wasn't it? Yeah, we were on the air for about nine or 10 minutes. Nine or 10 months and I quit.
对，因为你在想，我为什么要为 MTV 白白干这种活？不，实际情况是那是选举年，我们发生了一些模仿事件，这很不幸。约瑟夫·利伯曼（Joseph Lieberman），阿尔·戈尔（Al Gore）手下的副总统候选人，决定了他的竞选纲领，他要对好莱坞采取强硬态度，
Yeah, because you were like, why am I making this basically for free for MTV? No, what happened was it was an election year and we'd had some copycat incidences and which were unfortunate. And Joseph Lieberman, Vice Presidential nominee under Al Gore, decided his platform, he was gonna get tough on Hollywood,
具体针对我和 MTV。真好样哦。哦，他在媒体上把我们痛骂了一顿。在那之后，MTV 吓坏了。所以他们不得不指派一个 OSHA（职业安全与健康管理局）人员到我们的节目组，我们不能从四英尺高以上的地方跳下来，我们有所有这些新规矩。要按照我们以前的方式做节目是不可能的。
specifically me and MTV. Good for him. Oh, he just lambasted us in the press. And after that, MTV got scared. And so they had to assign an OSHA person to our show and we couldn't jump off things more than four feet high and we had all these new rules. And it was impossible to do the show the way that we do it.
所以我当时想，我们做的事虽然愚蠢荒谬，但对我来说意义重大，我绝不做阉割版的。所以我直接辞职了。对。听起来他们应该给这个节目指派一个“哦，见鬼”的人。嘿，你好吗？我挺好的。
So I was like, what we do is silly and absurd, but it means too much to me to do it watered down. So I just quit. Right. You know, it sounds like they should have assigned an, oh, shit person to this show. Hey, how are you? I'm all right.
看什么？太棒了。等等，所以 PJ，你做了这个节目，你和特雷恩以及斯派克一起完成的，正如你所提到的，伟大的斯派克·琼斯（Spike Jonze），我们都深爱和崇拜他。所以当你们，你们之前和斯派克的合作是怎样的？
Look at what? Wonderful. Wait, so PJ, so you do this show, you do this with Tremaine and with Spike, as you mentioned, the great Spike Jonze, who we love and adore. And so what was, when you guys, what was your involvement with Spike before that?
你们是因为滑板之类的事情成了好朋友吗？那是一种什么样的关系？肖恩，告诉特雷西斯派克·琼斯都做过什么。斯派克·琼斯导演了你最喜欢的一堆电影。你来告诉大家，你说。
Were you guys friendly from like skating and stuff? What was that relationship? Sean, tell Tracy what Spike Jonze has done. Spike Jonze directed a bunch of your favorite movies. You tell, you say. Being John Malkovich, Her, Where the Wild Things Are. Some of the greatest videos ever made, the Buddy Holly video for Weezer,
《变脑》（Being John Malkovich），《她》（Her），《野兽国》（Where the Wild Things Are）。制作过一些有史以来最伟大的音乐录影带，Weezer 的《巴迪·霍利》（Buddy Holly）MV，野兽男孩（Beastie Boys）的《破坏》（Sabotage）MV。一个有远见的人，品味非凡。他为一家滑板公司拍了一个非常棒的 MV《Pretty Sweet》，我不知道，里面有一个非常搞笑的家伙。他在《托德·玛格丽特》（Todd Margaret）里有一个小客串，我没说错吧？不，我们拍了两季的《托德·玛格丽特》。我跟你讲讲我最喜欢的关于斯派克的故事，
the sabotage video for Beastie Boys. A visionary, incredible taste. He made a great video for Pretty Sweet for a skateboard company that was, I don't know, featuring some guy who was really hilarious. He had a small arc on Todd Margaret, am I wrong? No, we did two seasons of Todd Margaret. I'll tell you my favorite story about Spike
当时我们正在英国和大卫·克罗斯（David Cross）一起制作那个节目。叫什么名字？叫《托德·玛格丽特的日益重要的决定》（The Increasingly Poor Decisions of Todd Margaret）。我们在拍这些场景，我们试图调查这个犯罪案件。所以斯派克扮演的角色开始模仿福尔摩斯，他戴着这顶帽子，拿着这个愚蠢的烟斗之类的东西。
when we were doing that show with David Cross and over in the UK. What was it called? Called the Increasingly Imported Decisions of Todd Margaret. And we're doing these scenes and we're like trying to investigate this crime. So Spike's character starts acting like Sherlock Holmes and he's got this hat on, this stupid pipe and stuff.
他还拿着这个记事本。而且他无论如何也记不住他的很多台词。然后他总是会笑场。你了解斯派克的，他总是咯咯笑，对吧？所以他说，无论如何我有这个笔记本。然后他说，我只要把我的台词写在笔记本里就行了。
And he's got this notepad. And he couldn't remember a lot of his dialogue anyway. And then he would always break. He'd start laughing all the time. You know Spike, he just kind of giggles, right? So he's like, I got this notebook anyway. And he's like, I'm just gonna write my dialogue in the notebook.
我说，行，太好了，来，我们就这么办。然后我们走进一个场景，我们站在那里，我们得和另一个角色对话。斯派克拿着他的笔记本开始说，我想，哦，天哪，这是什么，我说，你在照着念呢，你把它写在面前了。如果你在照着念，你的台词就接不上去了，老兄。他自己写的字他自己都认不出来。
I go, yeah, great, yeah, let's do that. So then we walk into a scene, we're standing there and we gotta talk to this other character. And Spike's holding his notebook and he starts going, I think, oh God, what is, and I go, you're reading, you've got it written down in front. You can't go up on your line if you're reading it, man. He couldn't read his own writing.
你在干什么？这就是他完全转向导演的时候。但你和斯派克，你们是什么关系？这源于什么？我和斯派克挺熟的，对吧？他为我朋友的乐队 Wax 导演了几个 MV。所以我，他在同一个朋友圈里。但是没有那么深。
What are you doing? This is when he went full tilt direction. But so you and Spike, what was that relationship? What did that come out of? I was friendly with Spike, right? He directed a couple of videos for my friend's band Wax. So I was, he was in the same kind of friend group. And, but I didn't have that much.
就像我们不单独出去玩。我们只是都在一个圈子里玩。当杰夫和我，我们在第二部《蠢蛋搞怪秀》之后，不，是《老大哥》滑板视频之后，我们知道，杰夫意识到我们有一群非常棒的家伙，我们讨论过做一个节目。
Like we didn't hang out alone. We just like all hung out in a group. And when we were, Jeff and I, we knew after the number two, Jack asked, excuse me, the big brother video, we're like, we got a pretty, Jeff recognized we have a really good group of guys and we talked about doing a show.
他说，我应该打电话给斯派克问他想不想做吗？斯派克和杰夫在马里兰州读的是同一所高中，沃尔特·惠特曼高中（Walt Whitman High）。所以杰夫给斯派克打了电话，谢天谢地他愿意加入。对，没错。所以然后，你就从一个节目过渡到了一部电影。对。
And he goes, should I call Spike to see if he wants to do it? The Spike and Jeff went to the same high school in Maryland, Walt Whitman High together. So Jeff called up Spike and, you know, thank God he was up for it. Yeah, right. So then, so then you went from a show to a film. Yeah.
那显然取得了巨大的成功。现在你们即将发行第四部。想出这些点子是一个怎样的过程？如果这个问题你已经被问过一百万遍了，我先道歉。对，我很着迷。我是一个超级超级狂热的电影迷。而且，是的，杰森的问题，我一直……
And that was obviously wildly successful. And now you're coming up on releasing the fourth. What's the process like to come up with these things? And I apologize if this is a question you've answered a million times. Yeah, I'm fascinated. I'm such a massive, massive fan of movies. And, and yes, Jason's question, I've always...
你们是坐在一张桌子旁，然后，你知道，分享一杯好饮料，想出一些疯狂的点子吗？还是比那更有条理一点？就像有一个编剧室之类的东西吗？就我个人而言，我独自一人时写得最好，不过我们可以，我们确实有编剧会议。杰夫和我，我们只是坐在那里互相抛出想法。
Do you sit around a table and just, you know, share a nice beverage and think up crazy ideas? Or is it a little bit more sort of structured than that? Like, is there like a writer's room kind of thing? Personally, I write best when I'm alone, but I can, we do have writers meetings. Jeff and I, we just kind of sit there and kick things back and forth.
我从动画片里得到很多灵感，尤其是《猫和老鼠》（Tom and Jerry）。当然，当然。那《威利狼和跑路鸟》（Coyote and Roadrunner）呢？对，对。对，新电影里有一个桥段，就是《威利狼和跑路鸟》。我把现实生活看作是一部动画片。
I get a lot of ideas from cartoons, Tom and Jerry especially. Of course, of course. What about Coyote and Roadrunner? Yeah, yeah. Yeah, there's one bit in the new movie, Straight, Coyote and Roadrunner. I look at real life like it's a cartoon.
这让我付出了不少代价。但对于《蠢蛋搞怪秀永久版》，在《蠢蛋搞怪秀 3》之后，我不知道我们是否还会拍另一部。如果你问演员阵容，他们会说我绝不会再拍一部。所以他们以为这永远不会发生。但我坚持写了 10 年。
Yeah. And that's cost me quite a few times. But for Jackass Forever, I, after Jackass Three, I didn't know if we'd ever do another one. If you ask the cast, they would say that I would never do another one. So they didn't think it was ever gonna happen. But I kept writing for 10 years.
所以我有一叠，我不知道，40、50 页的点子，几年前我把它们扔在早餐桌上，对杰夫说，我想再拍一部。这完全是意料之外的。他当时想，哦，该死。他并不，他并没有很兴奋。
So I had a stack of, I don't know, 40, 50 pages of ideas, which I threw on the breakfast table a couple of years ago and said, Jeff, I wanna do another one. And it was completely out of the left field. And he was like, oh, shit. He didn't, it wasn't excited.
他当时，因为他正在拍另一部电影，正焦头烂额，我能看到压力掠过他的面部。我猜每一个好的点子，第一直觉都是，哦，这太离谱了。我们不能这么做。这太可怕了。
He was, because he was in the middle of another movie and he was in the weeds and he just, I could just see pressure go across his face. I would imagine that every one of these ideas that are good ideas, the first instinct is, oh, well, that's just too far. We can't do that. That would be awful.
然后你不得不花另外 30 秒思考一下，然后你就会想，是的，但上一部的时候我们也是这么想的。但后来它成功了，虽然很痛苦，但确实很好笑。那么在哪个时间点，我想，因为我们年龄都差不多，身体从这些事情中在物理上和心理上反弹和恢复的能力开始受到一些考验。你有没有开始，你会不会开始在演出阵容里加入一些年轻人，这样他们可以承担其中一些事情？我的意思是，这一切是如何运作的？嗯，我们，那个问题的第一部分是什么？抱歉。
And then you have to think another 30 seconds about it and you go, yeah, but it's kind of like that's what we thought on the last one. But then it worked and it was painful, but it was funny. So at what point, I'd imagine, because we're all about the same age, the body's ability to rebound and recoup
第一部分是，嗯，第一次你——顺便说一句，这是个非常合理的问题，皮特。对，抱歉。我塞了一堆问题。我很抱歉。我是不是该放慢一点语速，或者应该加快？不，不，不。
from these things physically and a little bit mentally starts to become taxed a little bit. Do you start to like, do you start to cast younger guys as part of the troupe so that they can take on some of these things? I mean, how does all that work? Well, we, what was the first part of that question? Sorry.
我还是安静点吧。第一部分，抱歉。所以当你想到这些事情时，难道不觉得太过分了吗？哦，明白了。好吧。界限一直在被划定又被抹去，对吧？因为杰夫和我会有，
The first part about it is, well, the first time you- By the way, that's a really valid question, Pete. Yeah, I'm sorry. I'll pack a bunch in. I apologize. Let me slow down a little bit or should I speed up? No, no, no.
当我们想出一个游走在边缘的想法时，我们会想，把它拍下来看看效果如何。我们有这种奢侈，可以拍摄这么多不同的东西。如果我们事后观看觉得，这有点太过分了，那我们就把它抛弃。但我们宁愿选择拥有它
I'll just go quiet. The first part, sorry. So when you think up these things, doesn't it seem that it's too much? Oh, got it. Okay. The line is constantly getting drawn and erased, right? Cause Jeff and I will have,
却用不上，也不愿需要它却没有。至于身体的恢复能力，我只能谈谈我个人。我对自己的身体不是很敏感。我的意思是，我，我甚至不是在搞笑。我对自己的身体真的不是很敏感。但是我知道在拍摄《蠢蛋搞怪秀永久版》时，我已经干了 20 年了，
when we come up with an idea that's like riding that line, we're like, let's shoot it and see how it works. We have that luxury of just shooting so many different things. And if we view it afterwards or like, that's a little too much, then we cast it aside. But we always err on the side of having it
这将是我最后一部把生命押在上面的电影，对吧？有没有哪个特技是你没有做的，因为你只是觉得无论出于什么原因你想做但最终没做，仅仅是因为你觉得，你知道吗，那太危险了，真的会有人受伤的。嗯，我们把最大的特技放在了电影的结尾，
and not needing it aside from needing it and not having it. And as far as the body's ability to recoup, I can always talk about me personally. I'm not very in touch with my body. I mean, I'm just, I'm not even trying to be funny. I'm just not very in touch with my body. And, but I knew coming into Jackass forever, I've been doing this for 20 years
这样我们就能拍到我们想要的东西。我在，我知道具体日期，因为我不得不在医院度过周末。那是 2020 年 12 月 18 日。我想对一只动物搞个恶作剧，对吧？当然。我真的很想对一只动物搞恶作剧。对，它们罪有应得。
and this would be my last film where I put my life on the line, right? Is there a stunt that you didn't do because you just thought it was for whatever you wanted to do but never did just because you're like, you know what, that's just gonna be, somebody's gonna get really hurt. Well, we put my biggest stunts to the end of the film
所以我们想出的点子是，我要在一头公牛身上表演一个魔术，天哪，这可真不是个好主意。因为，我顺便说一句，我不得不做两次，因为第一头公牛好像没有，它狠狠地撞了我，而且在电影上看起来效果不好。那是那种“哦，我得再来一次”的情况。不管怎样，哇，我在医院度过了周末，因为我摔断了手腕、肋骨。
so we can get what we need. And I did a stunt on, I know the date because I had to spend the weekend in the hospital. It was December 18th of 2020. I wanted to prank an animal, right? Sure. I really wanted to prank an animal. Yeah, they deserve it.
我还得了脑震荡和脑出血。哦，天哪。所以，他妈的，老兄。但你看，对我来说，我只会去想特技本身的数学原理，并知道至少会发生这种情况，对吧？所以，没有哪个版本的特技会完美无缺地上演。
So we came up with, was I was gonna do a magic trick on a bull and boy, was that not a good idea. Cause the, I had to do it twice by the way, cause the first bull like didn't, he hit me hard and it didn't look good on film. It was one of those like, oh, I'm going again. But anyway, the, wow, I spent the weekend in the hospital cause I broke my wrist, my rib.
所以跟我聊聊，你愿意接受的疼痛和问题的百分比是多少，并将其视为这件事命中注定的结果？你知道，这就像，你怎么能被一头公牛撞了还指望能安然无恙地走开呢？所以你在每一个特技中都接受某种程度的损害，对吗？嗯，我正在做的事情是我完全不知道结果会如何。
I got a concussion and a brain hemorrhage. Oh my God. So, fuck man. But see, like to me, I would just think of the, just the math of the stunt itself and know that at a minimum, that's what's gonna happen, right? So like, there's no version of the stunt that goes perfectly.
所以我必须在心理上走进斗牛场，并接受这件事可能带来的任何结果。哦，天哪。这太勇敢了。我甚至不敢在酒店上冒一点风险。我知道，我只要看三星级就知道对我来说不会愉快。对吧？
So talk to me about, what is the percentage of pain and problem you're willing to accept as a fate accompli for this thing? You know, it's like, how do you get hit by a bull and expect to just kind of walk away? So you're accepting some kind of damage on every stunt, yes? Well, I'm doing things where I have no idea how they're gonna turn out.
这很简单。好吧，我从中获得了一个五星级的重击。所以，我今天坐在这里和你们说话。我能走能跑，对于我做过的所有事情，我一直极其幸运。你太棒了。
So I have to mentally walk into the bull ring and be okay with however this is going to turn out. Oh my God. That is so brave. I don't even take a risk on hotels. I know, I just, I can look at three stars and know it's not gonna be pleasurable for me. Right?
还有约翰尼，或者抱歉，PJ，你知道吗，你作为演员做了那么多伟大的工作，但我想，我猜你最著名的还是《蠢蛋搞怪秀》系列。你会怀念成为那个出来当演员并以这种方式被人知晓的家伙吗，而不是因为那些让你成名的事情？我的意思是，你也拍了很多电影。对，无数电影。作为演员。
It's just easy. Well, I got a five star hit out of it. So, and I'm sitting here today talking to you guys. I'm walking around, I've been extremely lucky for all the things I've done. You're amazing. And Johnny, or sorry, PJ, do you know the, you've done so much great work
对，我只是觉得，老兄，我能来到这里真是太幸运了。我很幸运能有今天的成就。在过去的 20 年里，我一直和同一批演员和同一群剧组一起工作。这只是一群朋友。我绝不会用这个去交换任何东西。其他的一切都只是锦上添花。对。
as an actor, but you're most known, I would say, I would guess, for the Jackass franchise. Do you miss being that guy who came out to become an actor and be known in that way rather than what's made you famous? I mean, you've made a lot of movies too. Yeah, tons of movies. As an actor.
作为一个演员，但我猜你最为人所知的，我会说，应该是《蠢蛋搞怪秀》系列。你会怀念当年那个想要成为一名演员并以那种方式为人所知，而不是以让你成名的方式出现的那种状态吗？我的意思是，你也拍了很多电影。是的，拍了大量的电影。作为一名演员。
Yeah, I just consider, man, I am lucky to be here. I am lucky to be where I'm at. I've gotten to work for the last 20 years with the same cast and the same crew. It's just a group of friends. And I wouldn't trade that for anything. And everything else is just gravy. Yeah.
是的，我只觉得，天哪，我能来到这里真是太幸运了。能有今天的成就我真的很幸运。过去20年里，我一直和同一班演员、同一帮工作人员共事。这只是一群朋友。我绝不会用这一切去换取任何别的东西。其他的一切都只是锦上添花。是的。
When you do, how did you like doing so? But Jackass did, you've done a lot of movies and a lot of those doors were open because of Jackass. And everybody's like, wow, this guy's funny and he's talented and he's handsome and blah, blah, blah. Oh, shucks. When you started working on those movies,
等你拍的时候，感觉怎么样？不过《无厘头搞怪秀》确实——你拍过很多电影，其中很多机会都是因为《无厘头搞怪秀》才敞开的。每个人都觉得，哇，这家伙真搞笑，有才华，长得又帅，等等等等。哦，天哪。当你开始拍那些电影的时候，
you know, I don't know, Dukes of Hazard and all these things, like, did you fit men in black? Were you like, oh, right on. Like, this is what I love doing more? Or were you like, fuck, I miss hanging with my guys? I wasn't torn like that. I was just happy to be able to have the Jackass career and to be doing movies on top of that.
你知道的，我也说不上来，《正义前锋》还有诸如此类的事情，比如，你觉得《黑衣人》适合你吗？你当时会想，哦，太棒了？就像，这是我更喜欢做的事吗？还是你会想，操，我好怀念跟我那帮兄弟鬼混的日子？我倒没有那么纠结。我只是很高兴能拥有《无厘头搞怪秀》带来的事业，而且在此基础之上还能拍电影。
Yeah, yeah. But I'm a kid from East Tennessee who probably had very, very, very low chances of making anything out of himself. I get the joke. Yeah. Dude, you know, talk to me about your family at PJ because when I was, I think one of the reasons,
对啊，对啊。但我只是个来自东田纳西州的小孩，他自己能闯出名堂的概率可能非常、非常、非常低。我懂这个梗。对啊。老兄，你知道的，跟我聊聊你在PJ的家人吧，因为当我——我想其中一个原因，
I'm guessing one of the reasons people connect so much and love the Jackass movies is because they, it's like a wish fulfillment. You get to be a kid again and do all these pranks and run around like a, like a Jackass. And when I was a kid, we, you know, single mom, dad left when I was young and there was no parenting. Talk about that.
我猜大家之所以这么有共鸣并且热爱《无厘头搞怪秀》电影，其中一个原因就是它们就像是一种愿望的实现。你可以再次变成一个孩子，做所有这些恶作剧，像个傻子一样到处乱跑。当我还是个孩子的时候，我们，你知道的，单亲妈妈，我小的时候爸爸就走了，根本没人管教。聊聊这个吧。
We would have, we would have knife fights in the dark. We would literally throw steak knives at each other. This is with your dad before he left. Yeah, one of my brothers like built darts out of like needles and threw them and they stuck in my back and like, there was a bunch of stuff, not nearly as dangerous as what you would do.
我们以前会，我们会在黑暗中进行刀战。我们真的会朝彼此扔牛排刀。这是在你爸离开之前发生的吗？对，我有个兄弟用针之类的东西做成飞镖，然后扔向我，扎在我的背上，还有诸如此类的一堆事情，虽然远不如你们干的那么危险。
Knife fights in the dark is pretty like, we wouldn't film that. Yeah. No, no, you wouldn't film that. And it was called tiger in the grass. And we would throw, and we'd turn off all the lights in the house and it was dark and we'd whip, we'd whip knives at each other.
黑暗中刀战听起来还挺像——我们可不会把那拍下来。对啊。不，不，你不会把它拍下来的。这游戏叫“草地里的老虎”。我们会扔，我们会把家里所有的灯都关掉，里面黑漆漆的，然后我们会拿刀互甩。
Anyway, so that's why I love the movies because they remind me of being a kid. But did you do any of that when you were, by the way, brothers, sisters, like how big, small was the family? And did you do any of that? I had, no, I never did tiger in the grass. Hello, my name's Sean Hayes and this is tiger in the grass.
总之，这就是为什么我喜欢这些电影，因为它们让我想起当年的童年。但你在——顺便问一句，兄弟姐妹们，家里人多不多？你小时候也玩过这些吗？我有，不，我从来没玩过“草地里的老虎”。你好，我叫肖恩·海斯，这就是“草地里的老虎”。
No, I never did that. I had two older sisters, eight and 10 years older. My dad told me I was one of those M&M babies. So what's that dad? He goes, you came between menstruation and menopause. Oh, wow. He said, the best part of you ran down your mama's crack, boy.
不，我从来没玩过。我有两个姐姐，分别大我八岁和十岁。我爸跟我说我是那种“M&M豆宝宝”。我爸说这是啥意思？他说，你是在月经和更年期之间蹦出来的。哦，天哪。他说，你身上最好的部分顺着你妈的缝隙流下去了，小子。
Wow. And then my mom, which would make it worse, she'd go, oh honey, it did not. I'm like, mom, that was a completely throwaway line until you justified it, right? Stretch it out, yeah. Now, is Rocco watching these things and doing the same thing and jumping off stuff
哇。然后我妈——这会让事情更糟糕——她会说，哦，亲爱的，才没有呢。我说，妈，本来这就是一句废话，直到你证明了它是真的，对吧？拉长来说，对吧。现在，罗科在看这些节目，然后也做同样的事，从各种东西上往下跳，
and you're having to rush him to the hospital? No, you know, most all of Rocco and our little friends have seen Jackass and they didn't even know about Jackass, right? Growing up. Oh, really? They knew Men in Black, they knew Dukes of Hazard, but you didn't show them this.
然后你不得不急忙把他送进医院？不，你知道的，罗科和我们的小伙伴们大部分都看过《无厘头搞怪秀》，而且他们甚至不知道有《无厘头搞怪秀》这回事，对吧？在他们成长过程中。哦，真的吗？他们知道《黑衣人》，知道《正义前锋》，但你没有给他们看这个。
No, I don't even think they knew about that. They knew Daddy was an actor, but Daddy was nice enough to never have to make him sit through his films. How old are they? They're 10 and 11, Rocco will be 12 in a few days. Anyway, we were sitting at the dinner table one night, Rocco was like, I don't know, eight or nine
对，我甚至觉得他们不知道那个。他们知道爸爸是个演员，但爸爸人很好，从来没让他们硬着头皮看自己的电影。他们多大了？他们一个10岁，一个11岁，罗科过几天就12岁了。总之，有一天晚上我们坐在餐桌旁，罗科大概是，我不知道，八九岁吧，
and he just goes, Jackass. And we're like, what? It was just out of the, it was like a reflexive. And so I had to like tell him, yeah, Dad does this. And I've shown him a couple of things, but since he's kind of wired like my father, I don't want to show him a lot of things. Yeah, because you're afraid that he's gonna say,
然后他突然冒出一句：“蠢蛋搞怪秀（Jackass）。”我们当时就想，什么？这纯粹是，就像是一种条件反射。所以我不得不告诉他，对，爸爸是干这个的。我给他看过一些片段，但既然他的性格有点随我爸，我不想让他看太多东西。对啊，因为你害怕他会说，
what the hell are you doing? No, I'm afraid he'll go, that seems like a good thing to do. Right, got it, right. I don't want him to get hurt. I had a moment a little while ago with Jason and I did this thing that Sean had done a couple of years ago,
你到底在干什么鬼？不，我害怕他会说，这事看起来挺靠谱的。对，明白了，对。我不想让他受伤。不久前我和杰森有过这么一个时刻，我做了肖恩几年前做过的一件事，
this live sitcom. We did an episode of the facts of life. And so Jason and I had terrible wigs on and stuff. And I remember one time I had my 13 year old, we were driving from the trailer like to set or whatever. And I'm wearing this crazy wig and this stupid costume. And I looked at him, he kind of looked at me and I was like, I said, is it pretty weird
这个现场情景喜剧。我们拍了一集《生活的事实》。所以我和杰森都戴着糟糕的假发之类的东西。我记得有一次，我的13岁儿子在车上，我们正从拖车开往片场之类的。我戴着这个疯狂的假发和这套愚蠢的服装。我看着他，他看了看我，然后我，我说，
that this is what your dad does? Exactly, yeah. And honestly, I thought he was gonna go like, yeah, it's fucking bonkers, man. Cause you look like a lunatic or whatever. And I'm 51 and I'm his dad. And he said, no, I think it's okay. I was like, oh, cool.
这不是很诡异吗，这就是你爸爸的工作？完全是，对吧。老实说，我以为他会说，对啊，这太操蛋了，老爸。因为你看上去就像个疯子或者别的什么。而且我已经51岁了，我是他爸。结果他说，不，我觉得这挺好的。我当时就想，哦，酷。
All right, all right. Because that's what they've grown up with. Yeah, they've grown up in the circus, right? Right with us. I saw one of those things where you guys were in the wigs and you slapped the cow walking shit out of Jason. And you guys were background. You guys weren't even in the main guy.
好吧，好吧。因为那是他们从小看到大的。对啊，他们就是在马戏团里长大的，对吧？和我们在一起。我看到过这样一个片段，你们戴着假发，狠狠地扇了杰森一巴掌，打得他屁滚尿流。你们当时只是背景板。你们甚至都不是主角。
He's trying to steal the thunder. Well, his mouth, he's got such a mouth on him. And the night before we'd done a dress rehearsal and he tried to jam my hand on the table in the background and I moved it. So this time I went on the offense and I was like, shut the hell up and I slapped him. It was so good.
他在抢风头。好吧，他那张嘴太能说了。前一天晚上我们排练过，他在背景里试图把我的手按在桌上，而我躲开了。所以这次我主动出击，我说，闭上你那张臭嘴，然后我扇了他一巴掌。那一幕太棒了。
It was so funny. You gotta stay awake if you're in the background. Yeah. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. PJ, is there anything that you haven't done in the entertainment world or a role you've always wanted to play or something that you haven't tackled yet
太搞笑了。当背景板也得保持清醒才行。对啊。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目中。PJ，在娱乐界里有没有什么事是你还没做过的，或者有没有哪个角色你一直想演，或者有什么挑战你还没尝试过，
that you wanna while you still can? Well, I love making documentaries and I wanna continue doing that. There's a couple we're circling right now. A role I've always wanted to play. You know, I always wanted to play Johnny Cash, but that got taken. Yeah, that got taken care of.
你想在还能动的时候去完成它？嗯，我喜欢拍纪录片，我想继续拍下去。目前我们正在筹划几部。我一直想演的一个角色。你知道的，我一直想演强尼·卡什，但那个角色已经被别人演了。对啊，那个已经有人演了。
Are you digging any documentaries that are on right now? Like, do you like the murder ones? Do you like the sports ones? The whole gamut. You know, I watched the other day, I think it's Operation Odessa. Have you seen that? Oh, yeah.
你现在有在追看什么纪录片吗？比如，你喜欢凶杀案题材的吗？你喜欢体育题材的吗？各种各样的都看。你知道的，前几天我看了，我觉得叫《敖德萨行动》。你看过吗？哦，对啊。
Oh, wait, yeah, that's about the submarine, right? Yeah. Yeah, the guys who tried to scam the Russian mob and the Cali cartel. Down in Florida, right? Yeah, the guy Tarzan who owned the place where porkies were shot at. It's very good.
哦，等等，对，那是关于潜水艇的对吧？对啊。对，那群试图诈骗俄罗斯黑手党和卡利贩毒集团的家伙。在佛罗里达那边，对吧？对，那个叫泰山的家伙，他拥有拍摄《猪肉卷》的那个地方。那部非常棒。
That thing's great. I love that shit. Did you see that, did you see that 100 foot wave? Do you see that one? I saw that and I loved it. I was so in and episode six, it ends. And so I keep checking for episode seven and it never happened.
那个真的太棒了。我喜欢那种玩意儿。你看了吗，你看了那个《百尺巨浪》吗？你看过那个吗？我看过，而且我超喜欢。我完全沉浸进去了，结果第六集就结束了。所以我一直在等第七集，但它再也没出过。
I thought there was more going to happen. It just kind of just went away. What's it about Laird Hamilton? No. No. It's about that other guy. Forget his name, the guy. It's incredible.
我以为还会有后续呢。结果它就那样没了。那是讲谁的？莱尔·汉密尔顿？不是。不是。是讲另一个家伙的。忘了叫什么名字了，那个人。太不可思议了。
Jason, you gotta see it, Shawn. So you gotta see it. It's incredible. But it's literally about a 100 foot wave, about a surfer? Yeah, it's about a guy who's like looking, the idea that there's this 100 foot wave out there and they end up in Portugal.
杰森，你得去看看，肖恩。所以你得去看。简直不可思议。但它真的是关于100英尺高的巨浪，是关于冲浪者的吗？对，是关于一个一直在寻找的家伙，那种认为外面有这样一个100英尺巨浪的想法，他们最终去了葡萄牙。
The wave is Nazare in Portugal. Oh, Will loves Portugal. I sure do. Ask him about Portugal. I wanna move to Portugal. This has been my thing for about the last year. Tuck in, guys. Well, no, it's great.
那个浪是葡萄牙的纳扎雷。哦，威尔很喜欢葡萄牙。我当然喜欢。问问他关于葡萄牙的事。我想搬去葡萄牙。这大概是我过去这一年里一直想做的事。听好了，伙计们。好吧，不，这很棒。
Murderville February 3rd on Netflix at eight o'clock and then Nazare Portugal. These are the things I talk about. The guy's name was Garrett McNamara. He's still going for it, him and all his buddies. Really? Yeah, not a young guy. Like he's our age, right?
2月3日，《谋杀村》在网飞八点档上线，然后是葡萄牙的纳扎雷。这些就是我常挂在嘴边的事。那家伙叫加勒特·麦克纳马拉。他还在继续挑战，他和他的那些好兄弟们。真的吗？对，不年轻了。就像他跟我们差不多大，对吧？
50, mid-50s, looks incredible. And he's the first guy, some dude reaches out to him and says, there's this incredible wave here in Nazare Portugal. And so he goes and he grabs these two yahoo's out of Ireland who've been doing big waves surfing off of Ireland. He's like, hey, do you guys wanna, you wanna tow me into this crazy wave?
50岁，50岁出头，状态好得惊人。他是第一个去的人，有个家伙找到他，跟他说，葡萄牙的纳扎雷这里有个不可思议的巨浪。于是他就去了，还从爱尔兰找了两个疯狂的家伙，他们一直在爱尔兰海域冲大浪。他说，嘿，你们俩想不想，想不想把我拖进这个疯狂的巨浪里？
And they're like, yeah, sure. And the big wave only happens in the winter. So like the conditions are brutal. And they go in and he tackles this huge fricking, it's nuts, man, it's nuts. I mean, just driving out to the wave on the jet ski is perilous. Yeah, yeah, it's pretty, it's pretty amazing.
他们就说，行啊，没问题。而且这种大浪只在冬天出现。所以环境极其残酷。他们冲了进去，他挑战了这个巨大无比的操蛋巨浪，太疯狂了，简直疯狂。我的意思是，光是开着水上摩托艇冲向巨浪本身就是极其危险的。对啊，对啊，这挺，这挺震撼的。
You know, one time, Jason, you wanna tell him about the thing that happened with your Tesla that time? Well, yeah. Cause we're talking about stunts and taking chances. Oh man, this one time I was trying to pull my golf bag out of the back seat of my Tesla real fast, real fast, too fast. And I hurt the very tip of my ring finger.
你知道的，有一次，杰森，你想跟他说说那次你开特斯拉发生的事吗？好吧，对。因为我们在谈论特技和冒险。哦，天哪，有一次我想把高尔夫球包从我的特斯拉后座上拿出来，动作非常快，太快了，快过头了。结果我弄伤了我无名指的最前端。
Oh man, I couldn't swing a golf club for about four or five weeks. Nor play flamenco guitar. Oh man. No, you couldn't do anything. And Sean, you hurt your fingers once, right? You were doing the music from Oklahoma and you went too fast.
哦，天哪，我有大约四五个星期没法挥高尔夫球杆了。也不能弹弗拉门戈吉他。哦，天哪。不，你什么都干不了。肖恩，你以前也弄伤过手指，对吧？你当时在弹《俄克拉荷马》里的音乐，结果弹得太快了。
Too fast. Right? Too fast on the keys. I can't say no during the number I can't say no. So Will, what else are you working on? What's your new show, Will? It's Murderville, it's on Netflix. Wait, so enough about Murderville.
太快了。对吧？按琴键按得太快了。我在那首《我不能说不》里根本说不了不。所以，威尔，你还在忙什么？你的新节目是什么，威尔？是《谋杀村》，在网飞上播。等等，关于《谋杀村》就说这么多吧。
Let's get back to Jackass, which is coming out on February 4th. February 4th, yeah. So this is, you're hanging up the Jackass, you're hanging up your spurs or what? I don't know what you'd say. Well, you know, after the first couple of films we were like, this is it.
让我们回到《无厘头搞怪秀》上来，它将在2月4日上映。2月4日，对。所以这是，你要挂靴不干《无厘头搞怪秀》了吗，你是要金盆洗手还是怎么着？我不知道你该怎么说。好吧，你知道的，前几部电影拍完后我们都觉得，这就是终点了。
And then we did a three and now here's a four. So we're never gonna say never again, but I would step back. Yeah, I was gonna say, could you infuse new talent into, to keep the franchise going? We have, like there's new cast in Jackass forever. We have five new cast members and they're great. Isn't it time for other people to get hit in the nuts?
然后我们拍了第三部，现在又有了第四部。所以我们永远不会把话说死，但我会退居幕后。对，我是想说，你们能不能注入一些新血液，让这个系列继续走下去？我们会的，比如《永远的无厘头搞怪秀》里就有新演员。我们有五个新演员，他们都很棒。难道不该让其他人去挨踢裤裆了吗？
Like you've been hitting the nuts enough, you know? Right, yeah. So we folded some young blood into the show and... PJ, was there ever that kind of, that white whale of a stunt or a thing that you were like, that you always kept in the back of your mind like, I'd love to ride on the back of a space shuttle or some shit, you know what I mean?
你们的裤裆挨踢的次数也够多了，对吧？对，没错。所以我们在节目里加入了一些新鲜血液，还有……PJ，有没有那种所谓的终极特技，或者你一直藏在心底的某种东西，就像，你一直惦记着，我真想坐着太空梭或者别的什么鬼东西上天，你知道我的意思吗？
Jump from a hot air balloon, jump over the Snake River. Sure, there's a lot of ideas that we really wanted. There's this one idea that we've had an idea for, I don't know, the last 10 years. I can't really say what it was and we got so close on this, but it went to the top of Paramount and they came back and they said, if you shoot this idea,
从热气球上跳伞，飞跃蛇河。当然，有很多我们真的很想实现的创意。有个创意我们在过去大概十年里一直有个想法。我其实不能说那是什么，我们离成功非常近，但这个方案呈到了派拉蒙的高层那里，他们回话说，如果你把这个创意拍出来，
it's gonna be at least like $10 million for insurance. And it just was prohibitive and it broke my heart because I thought we were actually gonna get to pull it off. But maybe one day we can. And I became obsessed with getting the jackass flag on the moon. It's not really a stunt or a prank, but I really want to someone plant the jackass flag
光是保险费就至少得1000万美元。这实在是让人望而却步，这让我心碎，因为我以为我们真的能把它搞定。但也许有一天我们可以。而且我迷上了把“无厘头搞怪秀”的旗子插到月球上。这其实不是什么特技或恶作剧，但我真的很想让某人把无厘头搞怪秀的旗子插在月球上。
on the moon. PJ, are you like a health food nut? Do you do that kind of shit? Do you like eat well? Like you always seem like you're kind of in good shape and are you that kind of thing? I'm not a health food nut, but I try to eat good. I grew up eating so poorly, right?
PJ，你是个健康饮食狂魔吗？你会搞那种鬼把戏吗？你喜欢吃得健康吗？你看起来总是身材保持得挺好，你是那种人吗？我不是健康饮食狂魔，但我尽量吃得健康。我小时候饮食太不健康了，对吧？
In Tennessee, like, I never drank water really growing up. We would get, we drank Coca-Cola's all day long. You know, we'd go, that was what we drank and mom cooked with like so much sugar and butter and around 13 or 14, I'm like, God, this doesn't feel right. I need to start eating like chicken and rice. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Jason?
在田纳西州，就像，我小时候几乎从不喝水。我们喝的都是，整天都在喝可口可乐。你知道的，我们就去，那就是我们喝的东西，我妈做饭时会放超多的糖和黄油，到了13或者14岁时，我心想，天哪，这感觉不对劲。我得开始吃鸡肉和米饭了。对啊，对啊，对啊。杰森？
Yeah, chicken and rice sounds great except for the rice part. Now, Jason, you won't eat rice, is that right? I will eat rice when I'm looking at rice and it looks great when I'm at a Japanese restaurant or something, but yeah, no, I don't have like a bunch of carbs and starch as a general daily, three meals a day, you know, stuff me full of garbage.
对，鸡肉和米饭听起来不错，除了米饭部分。现在，杰森，你不吃米饭，对吧？当我在日本餐厅看到米饭而且它看起来很诱人时，我会吃米饭，但对，总的来说我不会每天三餐都吃一堆碳水化合物和淀粉，你知道的，把我塞满垃圾食品。
Yeah, rice, oh yeah, I mean, rice is really garbage. You're right. No, but it's like, it's just, it's just, what is it? It's just like substance. I want protein and I want vegetables and I want fruit. Right, and what's the name of the dance troupe you're in again? Sorry, you're a professional dancer, I'm guessing,
对，米饭，哦，对啊，我是说，米饭真的是垃圾。你说的对。不，但它就像，它只是，它是什么？它只是一种充饥物。我想要蛋白质，我想要蔬菜，我想要水果。对，你加入的那个舞蹈团叫什么名字来着？抱歉，从你的谈吐来看，我猜你是个专业舞者。
by the way you talk. I think Jason, I said, I accused Jason the other day that he's looking, his goal is he just wants to, just barely dip below 100. He just wants to get below 100 pounds. I want to look ill, that's the goal. I had one time I was working on this thing and this costumer and I was like losing a lot of weight
我想杰森，我说，我前几天指责杰森说他看起来，他的目标就是他只想，勉强掉到100磅以下。他只想体重降到100磅以下。我想让自己看起来生病了一样，这就是目标。有一次我在拍某个东西，有个服装助理，当时我正在疯狂减肥，
and she goes, well, you can't get too skinny. And I said, that's what I always say. But no, I just, I don't know. Don't you feel better when you got gasoline in your car and said, you pour orange juice in your tank and your car won't move. I'm trying to put in my body what it needs to run right. What?
她就说，嗯，你不能瘦得太过头了。我说，这也是我常说的话。但不是，我只是，我不知道。当你的汽车加满汽油时，你不是会感觉更好吗？如果你往油箱里倒橙汁，你的车是开不动的。我只是在往我的身体里补充它正常运转所需要的营养。什么？
I just had a massive glass of orange juice before this. What do you, orange juice in the car? None of it adds up. It's a tough thing to follow there. Sean, you eat kind of whatever you want, right? Yeah. Carbs in the morning, carbs at night. The marshmallow spread.
在这之前我刚喝了一大杯橙汁。你刚才说什么？往车里倒橙汁？这完全说不通啊。这很难接话啊。肖恩，你想吃什么就吃什么，对吧？对。早上吃碳水，晚上吃碳水。棉花糖酱。
Yeah. I just had like three s'mores last night. Oh, great story. So did you, thanks for sharing that with everybody, with our listeners. You want me to teach you how to make them? Our listeners going crazy. Yeah.
对。我昨晚刚吃了三个夹心棉花糖饼。哦，好故事。所以你，谢谢你跟所有人分享这个，跟我们的听众分享。你想让我教你怎么做吗？我们的听众都快疯了。对啊。
Did you listen to this week's smart list? Sean had three s'mores and never expanded on it. How do you expand on a s'more? It's two graham crackers, marshmallows. Were you on a fucking camping trip? No, I do them over the stove. I roast the marshmallows over the stove. Wait a second.
你听这一周的《SmartLess》了吗？肖恩吃了三个夹心棉花糖饼，却没多说什么。吃个夹心棉花糖饼还有什么好细说的？就是两块全麦饼干，棉花糖。你当时是在去他妈的露营吗？不，我在炉子上面做。我在炉子上面烤棉花糖。等一下。
And I use two of them. This is a true story? Yeah, this is a true story. You and Scottie made s'mores last night. No, he doesn't need them. He doesn't like them. I put two marshmallows, takes two, and then you put a big chunk of Hershey's chocolate bar
我用了两个。这是个真实的故事吗？对，这是个真实的故事。昨晚你和斯科蒂做了夹心棉花糖饼。不，他不需要吃。他不喜欢吃。我放了两个棉花糖，得用两个，然后你放上一大块好时巧克力，
and two graham crackers and you just stuff your fucking face. Because you felt like, well, you know, I want a little treat. I'm going to make this one. Yeah, you know what? Now I'm talking about, I'm going to have it after this. You know why? Because there's something about being an adult
再加上两块全麦饼干，然后你就可以往你那张逼嘴里狂塞了。因为你觉得自己，嗯，你知道的，我想犒劳自己一下。我要做这个。对啊，你懂的？现在说起这个，我等下做完这个就要吃一个。你知道为什么吗？因为当了成年人之后有一种奇妙的感觉，
where you don't have to ask permission to eat sweets. Right, but you've been an adult for over 30 years. So you're acting like a kid who escaped from fat camp. I mean, what do you, Jason said the other day, he was like, hey, look, I mean, humans, he said, humans are the only animals that eat more than once a day and bubble, we should only eat once a day. And then immediately everybody's like,
那就是你吃甜食不需要请求批准。对，但你当成年人都三十多年了。所以你的行为举止就像一个从减肥夏令营逃出来的小孩。我的意思是，你，杰森前几天说，他说，嘿，听着，人类，他说，人类是唯一一种一天吃不止一顿饭的动物，喋喋不休，我们应该一天只吃一顿饭。然后大家立刻就说，
what about cows that graze the whole day? Oh yeah, he's like, oh yeah, I guess so. I guess so. I'm not smart, I just have ideas. They're not great ideas or good ideas. I just get ideas and then I spit them out. Is there a jumping off point? Yeah, just start a conversation, enjoy.
那成天吃草的牛算怎么回事？哦对，他就像，哦对，我想也是。我想也是。我不聪明，我只是有些想法。它们算不上什么伟大的想法或好点子。我只是有了想法然后把它吐出来。有没有什么切入点？对，就开启一段对话，尽情享受吧。
Are you, you don't smoke, do you smoke cigarettes? I tried to when I was 19. Yeah. I did it for like a month. I would go to the Hollywood billiards every day and shoot pull, trying to be like fast Eddie Felsen in the hustler. But when I'd been over to shoot,
你，你不抽烟吧，你抽烟吗？我19岁的时候尝试过。对。我抽了大概一个月。我每天都会去好莱坞台球厅打台球，试图模仿《江湖浪子》里的快手埃迪·费尔森。但当我弯腰去击球时，
the smoke would get in my eyes and they would start running and then I would start sneezing and I'm asthmatic. And so I just, I stopped that. And honestly, I didn't even know at the time that people inhaled. I would just suck in the cigarette and blow it right back out. And years later, they're like,
烟雾会飘进我的眼里，它们开始流泪，然后我就会开始打喷嚏，我有哮喘。所以我干脆就不抽了。老实说，我当时甚至不知道人们是把烟吸进肺里的。我只是把烟吸进嘴里然后又直接吐了出来。多年后，他们说，
you inhale it down your lungs. I'm like, I had no idea. Well, good. You avoided a lot of stupidity. Oh, I wouldn't say that. What about pot or gummies or that kind of thing? Anything like that? You know what?
你要把它吸进肺里。我说，我根本不知道。好吧，很好。你避免了很多愚蠢的行为。哦，我可不这么说。那大麻或软糖或者诸如此类东西呢？有这类东西吗？你知道吗？
I love the idea of weed. I love the idea of weed, but it hits me wrong. It makes me dizzy. It makes me go deaf. I can't, I lose my cognitive skills. Yeah, yeah. Not Sean. Sean just goes right to the s'mores.
我喜欢大麻的概念。我喜欢大麻的概念，但它对我的反应不对劲。它让我头晕。它让我耳鸣。我做不到，我失去了认知能力。对啊，对啊。肖恩可不会。肖恩直接奔向夹心棉花糖饼。
Yeah, absolutely. I'd love to just creep in with a camera and, you know, from Sean's back door there, just come in and just catch him standing over the stove. Cover my face. I want to know what song he's humming when he's making his s'mores. You just walk in the Buffalo Bill headset, you know?
对，绝对的。我真想拿着摄像机悄悄溜进去，你知道的，从肖恩家的后门进去，直接走过去拍下他站在炉子旁边的样子。遮住我的脸。我想知道他做夹心棉花糖饼时在哼什么歌。你直接戴着水牛比尔的夜视仪走进去，你知道的？
The Night Vision goggles. The pride from Silent of the Lands. It puts the s'mores in the basket, am I right? Yeah. By the way, we did do a takeoff on that bit and it's one of the best things we ever shot in Jackass Forever. We lured the cast to this room.
夜视护目镜。来自《沉默的羔羊》的恶作剧。把夹心棉花糖放进篮子里，我说的对吧？对。顺便说一句，我们确实模仿了那个桥段，这是我们在《永远的无厘头搞怪秀》里拍过的最棒的事情之一。我们把演员们引诱到这个房间里，
We staggered their call so it'll be two at a time and they thought they were watching me do this stunt. So they would get in the room, we would lock the door, turn out the lights and they couldn't see anything. And we psychologically absolutely tortured them and physically too, a little, but mostly it was psychological. And just to see how they interacted with each other
我们错开他们的集合时间，所以一次进两个人，他们以为自己是在看我表演这个特技。所以他们一进房间，我们就锁上门，关掉灯，他们什么也看不见。我们在心理上绝对地折磨了他们，肉体上也有一点，但主要是心理上的。光是看他们如何互相交流，
was made the whole bit. Like Dave England and Aaron McGeehy acted like an old married couple and they were just screaming at each other the whole time. And clearly I'm the one who's causing all the chaos but they took it out on each other. I can't wait for you to see that one. I can't wait.
就让整个桥段变得无比精彩。比如戴夫·英格兰和亚伦·麦基希表现得像一对老夫老妻，他们全程都在对彼此尖叫。显然我才是制造所有混乱的那个人，但他们却把气撒在了对方身上。我等不及让你们看那一幕了。我等不及了。
Wow, that's awesome. Were you just filming all with like Night Vision goggles? Yeah, yeah. What's it like insurance? You were talking about the high insurance or the paramount like it must be a fucking nightmare for them because these guys, all the, everything in this world is run by lawyers.
哇，那太棒了。你们全程都是用夜视护目镜拍的吗？对，对。保险是怎么回事？你刚才提到高额保险或者派拉蒙公司——对他们来说这一定是个他妈的噩梦，因为这些家伙，这世界上的所有事情都是由律师运营的。
And so everything's prohibitively expensive. Like when you go, yeah, we want to make another jackass. They're like fucking co-legal because they're the first stop. Right. Well, I think on the TV show we've been, we lost our insurance at one time. And on the first movie,
所以每件事的成本都高得离谱。比如当你去说，嘿，我们想拍另一部《无厘头搞怪秀》。他们就像他妈的联合法律顾问一样，因为他们是第一道关卡。对。好吧，我想在电视节目里的时候，我们曾经有一段时间失去了保险。而在第一部电影上，
they didn't ensure the entire movie. They treated it obviously back then they treated the whole movie as a negative pickup. They're like, here's some money. We don't have anything to do with it. Yeah. So they insured per bit. So one bit we wanted to do with Pontius
他们并没有给整部电影投保。很显然，在那个年代，他们把整部电影当作买断式成品收购来对待。他们就像是，给你点钱。这跟我们没关系。对。所以他们是按具体桥段来投保的。所以我们想跟庞蒂厄斯拍的一个桥段是，
to take him to a Pentecostal church dressed as the devil and handle snakes with the, you know, the congregation. It was gonna be like $5 million to insure and our first movie cost $6 million. So we couldn't do that. Wow. But after that, they just insured the entire movie. Wow.
带他去一个五旬节派教堂，打扮成恶魔的样子，跟会众一起玩蛇。这个桥段的保费要500万美元，而我们第一部电影总共才花了600万美元。所以我们拍不了那个。哇。但那之后，他们就开始为整部电影投保了。哇。
They didn't insure it per bit. I did bring up the example of the one bit for Jackass 4 that was gonna be like $10 million deductible or something. But that's like one of those things, you know, like we all know when you're going to do a job and you got to fill out that insurance thing and they'll be like, do you plan on operating a motor vehicle between now
他们不再按单个桥段投保了。我确实提到了《无厘头搞怪秀4》里那个桥段的例子，当时那个桥段的免赔额大概是1000万美元左右。但这就像那种事，你知道的，就像我们都知道当你去应聘一份工作，你得填那份保险表格，他们会问，你计划在拍电影的这段时间内驾驶机动车辆吗？
and the time you're shooting the movie? That seems pretty goddamn tame compared to that. Yeah, not only do I plan on being in a motor vehicle I'm jumping one off a parking garage while I'm shooting myself. What? It's so funny. Like on our movies, I can do whatever I want really.
跟那个比起来，这听起来可真是温顺得该死啊。对，我不但打算坐机动车辆，我还要在一边开枪的同时把它从停车场楼顶开飞出去。什么？太搞笑了。就像在我们的电影里，我真的想干嘛就干嘛。
But if I go on a Hollywood movie, they have a stuntman lined up for me and they don't want me to do any stunts. And it's frustrating. How do Hollywood stuntmen, how do they deal with you? Like when you, do you meet stuntmen and they give you like a, all right, man. Good for you.
但如果我去拍好莱坞电影，他们会为我安排好替身演员，他们不希望我做任何特技。这太令人沮丧了。好莱坞的特技演员们，他们是怎么对待你的？比如当你们见面时，特技演员们会给你一种，好吧，老兄。干得漂亮。
I remember on the first movie I did, Jackass was just coming out and it was lunchtime in the stunt guys were like, hey Knoxville, you can come sit with us. And it meant so much to me. They're like, we don't let actors sit with us, but you can sit with us. And so I was so touched
我记得我拍第一部电影的时候，《无厘头搞怪秀》刚刚上映，当时正是午休时间，特技演员们说，嘿，诺克斯维尔，你可以过来和我们坐一块儿。这对我有很大意义。他们就像是，我们通常不让演员和我们坐一起，但你可以和我们一起坐。所以我当时非常感动，
because they've always been super nice to me. And I really, what they do blows me away. They're so talented and gifted and trained. And so we get along very well. That same thing happened with Jason, the hair and makeup department. They're like, you can come eat with us. Wait, just one last question, PJ,
因为他们对我都超级好。我真心觉得他们做的事情让我惊叹不已。他们太有才华、太有天赋、训练有素了。所以我们相处得非常好。杰森也遇到过同样的事，发型和化妆部门的人说，你可以过来和我们一起吃。等等，最后一个问题，PJ，
just about the injuries. I know you get asked this all the time, but you had touched on the, by the way, thank God you're doing well from all the things you listed back in December, almost a year ago, the brain hemorrhage and all that. Is there anything that's lasted that you have to now live with because of that?
关于受伤的问题。我知道别人老是问你这个问题，但你刚才提到了——顺便说一句，谢天谢地，你现在身体恢复得很好，距离你去年12月（差不多一年前）列举的那些病情，脑出血以及所有这些。有没有什么后遗症是你现在必须带着它生活的？
I have to live with all my past injuries and we'll see where that comes out. You know, I've had like 16 concussions, but my biggest one, and by the way, I'm, like I said earlier, I'm not very in touch with my body. So, and I figured I did this to myself, right? So I get up every morning just thankful and grateful.
我必须带着我过去所有的伤病生活，至于以后会怎样我们拭目以待。你知道的，我有过大约16次脑震荡，但我最严重的一次是——顺便说一句，正如我刚才所说，我对自己的身体状况不是很敏感。所以，我想这都是我自找的，对吧？所以我每天早上醒来都充满感激和谢意。
But my back, I have two blown discs in my lower back. So that's something I have to deal with, just with exercise and anti-inflammatories and, but I'm so lucky. I've had some stunts that almost had forever consequences five or six times. I've almost dead five or six times, so. Jason, didn't you have a very successful day
但我的背部，我下背部有两个椎间盘突出。所以这是我必须面对的问题，只能通过锻炼和抗炎药来控制，但我已经很幸运了。我有过五六次差点造成永久性后果的特技表演。我曾死过五六次，所以。杰森，你不是带着两个突出的椎间盘度过了非常成功的一天吗？
with two blown discs? What were you saying about that? You had said, what was the word that you said? I have to live with it, and that's all I'll say. Is that so wrong? It's a high class problem. DJ, you stay safe, please. Yes.
你当时是怎么说的？你当时说的是哪个词？我必须带着它生活，这就是我要说的全部。这有那么不对吗？这是高端局的问题。DJ，请注意安全。好。
We appreciate your sacrifice. Yes. We sure do. My goodness, what a lot of fun you've given us. We will see you personally very soon. Thank you for spending an hour with us. Yeah, man, thank you so much for coming on, all the best with the movie, Hope It Kills,
我们感谢你的牺牲。对。我们当然感谢。天哪，你给我们带来了多少快乐。我们很快就会亲自见到你。谢谢你花了一个小时陪我们。对啊，老兄，非常感谢你能来，祝你的新电影一切顺利，希望它票房大爆，
and I'll definitely be watching. You're the best. Thanks, man. Thank you for having me on. I really appreciate it. Thanks, PJ. All right, bye-bye. See you, pal.
我一定会去看的。你最棒了。谢谢，老兄。谢谢你邀请我来。我真的很感激。谢谢你，PJ。好啦，拜拜。再见，老兄。
Bye, pal. You know, I don't think I've ever met him, and he's really funny, and he's really personable. I didn't think he would be that. Yeah, he's that guy's just, there's no Hollywood in him whatsoever. Yeah, he's great. He's super engaging,
再见，老兄。你知道的，我觉得我以前从没见过他，他真的很搞笑，而且非常平易近人。我没想到他会是那样的人。对啊，那家伙身上完全没有好莱坞演员的架子。对啊，他太棒了。他非常有吸引力，
and I love how sort of honest he is about everything, every stage of his life, and then coming to LA, and doing the Jackass, and doing all of that, and he's just very sort of open, which is amazing. And how wild that everybody has like a different journey, like he came out here to be an actor, and he did. He's done tons of great movies, but he's known for being this like stunt crazy person.
而且我喜欢他对待一切事情的那种坦诚，他人生中的每一个阶段，然后来到洛杉矶，拍摄《无厘头搞怪秀》，做所有这些事情，他都非常坦诚，这太了不起了。而且多么疯狂啊，每个人都有不同的人生轨迹，比如他来这里是为了当演员，他也确实做到了。他拍了无数优秀的电影，但他却因为是个疯狂的特技狂人而闻名。
Everybody, you just don't know where you're gonna end up. Yeah, I wonder what the percentage of people, I wonder what the percentage is of people who go to, let's say college, studying up on a career, and actually do that, you know? I feel like a bunch of success comes on the way to doing something different. Right, as long as you're pointed in a direction,
所有人，你永远不知道自己最终会走到哪一步。对啊，我想知道那些人的比例是多少，我想知道去上大学、学习某个职业并最终从事那个职业的人的比例是多少，你知道吗？我觉得很多成功都是在做不同事情的过程中降临的。对，只要你朝着一个方向前进，
forks will emerge. It's become huge for him, but I can't wait for that movie. I've seen all of them. Boy, they're laugh out loud. Yeah, I would be so anxious going into one of those things, even just thinking up the stunts. Like, well, you know, that feels safe, and like I wouldn't be worried about that,
岔路自然会出现。这对他的意义太重大了，但我等不及要看那部电影了。我都看过。天哪，它们让人捧腹大笑。对啊，如果让我去拍那种节目，我会焦虑死的，哪怕只是构思特技的时候。比如，嗯，这感觉很安全，而且我觉得我不会为此担心，
but then it's like, well, that's not gonna be entertaining footage. It's gotta be something that is really frightening in concept, and then to actually execute, it's even more frightening. But also like, what about that notion he was saying about getting, you know, the bowl, go, you know, playing a trick on a bowl,
但随后就会想，那可就没什么娱乐性了。那必须是那种在概念上就让人极其恐惧的东西，而真正去执行它，则会更加恐惧。但还有，关于他说的那个概念，你知道的，去挑逗公牛，你知道的，对公牛搞恶作剧，
and then like it really hurt, but they didn't get it on camera. Take two. So yeah, take two with the bowl. Yeah, no thanks. And again, there's no way that nothing happens when you stand in front of a bowl, and I think I know the one he's talking about, right?
然后结果伤得很惨，但他们没有把它拍下来。第二条。所以，对，跟公牛拍第二条。好吧，谢了。话说回来，当你站在公牛面前时，绝对不可能什么事都不发生，我想我知道他说的是哪一个，对吧？
Where the bowl charges you and flips you over, it's back. I mean, how do you, you can't land that. I don't care what a great gymnast you are or whatever. Yeah. That's what they're selling, you know? And God bless them. I do not have the backbone for that. I'll do it, I'll do it too.
公牛向你冲过来把你掀翻在地的那个。我的意思是，你怎么，你根本无法着陆。我才不管你是个多么伟大的体操运动员还是别的什么。对啊。这就是他们卖点所在，你知道的？上帝保佑他们。我可没有那种骨气。我也干不了，我也干不了那个。
I can't watch it. It does make me uptight too when I see it, because I get, with stuff like that, I get a little bit nervous, so I can't watch that stuff at night. So at night, I'm not gonna watch that, because at night, what I'll do is, before bed, I'd rather, you know, be, listen to a lullaby.
我都看不了。看到这些我也会觉得紧张，因为对于这种东西，我会感到有点焦虑，所以我晚上可不能看那种东西。所以在晚上，我才不看那个呢，因为在晚上，我要做的是，在睡觉前，我宁愿，你知道的，去听一首摇篮曲。
Lullaby. Whoa, that was a good one, aren't it? Bye. Woof. That's good, that's very good. Smart. What? Smart.
摇篮曲。哇，这转折真不错，对吧？再见。汪。真不错，这太棒了。聪明。什么？聪明。
What? SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarve, and Bennett Barberco. SmartLess. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus
什么？《SmartLess》由迈克尔·格兰特·泰瑞、罗布·阿姆贾夫和贝内特·巴尔贝科100%有机手工打造。SmartLess。我们的下一期节目将在两周后发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上抢先收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上的 Wondery Plus 或 Wondery 应用程序，抢先收听无广告版。
in Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。